this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman
and lastly Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
it's already celebrating 2020 [ __ ] we
don't get to end the show like we always
do what time is it right now four
minutes to or many 344 minutes ladies
gentlemen 2018 has been a weird
wonderful year and we're all still here
and despite you know all the complaints
we have about everything out there in
the world and whatnot we're still here
having a good time together thank you
for joining us
thank you for supporting the show for as
long as you have and whatnot Thanks
we love you guys honestly yeah we really
do when we started this eight and a half
years ago we never imagined it would
become what it has become and to have
people around the world listen to the
show
via the podcast and have so many people
show up not only here at home at the
improv but around the country hell
around the world that when we take the
show on the road it is its it is our
pleasure and truly are honored to be
able to perform and to entertain you
guys and to interact with you it's such
a blast and 20:19 of course as we get a
fresh start everybody gets a fresh start
you get to begin again
so if you've been sitting there thinking
about like oh there's some [ __ ] I've
always wanted to do 2019 is the year to
do it what are you waiting for give it a
shot man doesn't matter what it is shoot
the [ __ ] moon it's no such thing as
failure because if you get that wrong
guess what you figure it out you get it
right the next time
failure is just success training so as
we head into 2019 figure out what you
want to do and [ __ ] do it this year
I'm doing mine I'm going to reboot 2019
Jay and Silent Bob reboot
two minutes two minutes he's gonna be
there I'm gonna be there and [ __ ]
hopefully y'all could come visit while
we're shooting the movie because they
need big crowd scenes anything you got
to save it yeah real quickly I lost I
lost a job and many of you people have
been in your situation where you lose a
job and you look around you say what am
I gonna do now and how do I pick myself
up and how do i how do I move forward
how do I provide for my family and this
year I started my own thing with the
Ralph report and many of you showed up
in a big way and you show up every day
Monday through Friday to listen to it
and that has been it's like opening a
little mom-and-pop shop next to a
Walmart you know but you people show up
and you're there and you listen and you
enjoy it and it has been a godsend and
largely the audience from that show
comes from this show and I would want to
thank you for your support about that as
well but you can do it if you want to if
you find yourself on the outs and you've
been let go by some giant monolithic
corporation you don't have to look for
another monolithic corporation to go
work for you you can do what you want to
do and still provide for your family and
make something work for yourself so do
that for yourselves as well to find
success for yourself this year's ladies
Evelyn don't define it next to what
somebody else thinks success is you know
what your own success is here comes the
one-minute countdown one minute to 2019
I never imagined that I would be alive
this [ __ ] law
where's my wife is my wife now Christian
this chin hairs Jen here she's on her
way
Jen's on her way send my good lady wife
up there his own life light sabers
holiday light sabers I want to thank you
for these joints I misspoke this [ __ ]
ever thank you thank you for celebrating
thirty Zangara to us where she come
there we go 16:15
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
2018 give it up for the mailing office
around [ __ ] garbage for my besties
body and babble brother mr. Kevin Smith
and that is Hollywood battle over this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman
babble the bug off get not only wouldn't
that be me
[Music]
you
[Music]